Hi, I'm Onela. That's Joel. And we built
Ace, a live AI voice tutor that runs a
full lesson start to finish reliably.
The trick is LLM is not in charge.
If you have shipped a multi-step agent,
you know this moment. It's near the
demo, then a real user gets in and
halfway through the agent decide it's
done. Or skip a step, or even loops. The
demo never show you that.
And the first fix everyone reaches for
is prompt this harder, add more holes.
But reliability was never a prompting
problem. It's a control problem. Think
of it this way. The model is the talent,
and the harness is the director. The
model is brilliant at delivering a line,
but it's really terrible at remembering
if it's on step three of six. So we stop
asking it to.
A lesson is a small state machine with
intro, teach, check, grade, advance, and
wrap.
Each step sends the model a neural
contract. Do this one thing, return it.
The harness validates what's comes back,
advance the state, and decide what's
next. The model never decide where we
are. That's the design. Joel is going to
show you the harness thing.
>> Yeah. So,
when we think about the frontier models
of today, let's take for example
um Opus 4.7 Cloud from Anthropic,
you see that oftentimes people leverage
the model for essentially everything.
For the thinking, for the processing,
right? And for everything in between.
While that can be good, it's not always
effective in situations like ours, where
we are building a live AI tutor that is
speaking back and forth with students.
Right? For something like this, we had a
need to actually build something that is
reliable, something that is
cost-effective, and something that is
fast.
Right? So, this is where the idea of
leveraging the concept of harness
engineering has come in.
Where instead of having a model that is
really intelligent, sort of go through
everything for us, we will build all of
these steps that are needed and provide
only the input required for the model to
execute a specific scenario. So, when we
were building ACE, we actually thought
very deeply about state machines. Right?
What is the step right now? And what is
the possible steps that could come
after? And within each of the steps,
what are concrete things that we can
provide to the model so that it is
confined to that specific action, it is
confined to that specific step at that
particular moment, and only execute what
needs to be done.
So, by doing this, instead of having a
very heavy model like a 4.7, we were
actually able to rely on something like
a Haiku 4.5,
which is a much smaller model, doesn't
have as much reasoning capabilities, but
because of the harnessing around it,
it's still able to perform at the level
in which we expect, saving money, saving
time, and saving latency. So, let's go
ahead and play this recording, which
will show us logs um about a particular
lesson.
So, as you can see in this video,
especially on the right side, we see
logs on all of the different harnessing
that are happening. [clears throat]
Right? So, for example, we see that
there's harnessing for a section, which
provides input to the model about
exactly what to speak about, what to do.
We have harnessing about drawing on the
whiteboard. We have harnessing that
deals with clearing the queue. We have
steps to how to end the lesson and
everything in between, right? So,
everything that would allow us to
actually build the lesson in a way that
is reliable even if there's a new
scenario that comes in. We try to
incorporate that in our state machine.
We try to incorporate that with within
the lesson, right? So, again, the model
all it worries about is given an input,
it knows which action to take and it
provides the output of that action.
Right? And so, the model never really
um
has to think. It proposes, but
ultimately it is the harness that
decides. And so, for his A specifically,
there are three things that we wanted to
think about. Like, when is the lesson
done is one, right? Did the student
actually get it right? Like, did they
actually learn in the way they were
supposed to? And what comes next, right?
And so, everything that comes within
those three categories, all of the
different questions, all of the
different actions that the models needs
to take, we have engineered that outside
of the model, right? So, again, it's an
input, the model receives it and gives
us an output, right? And so, this is
very, very important and we have found
this to be very remarkable.
Right? So, again, the the this is
applicable to really everything, right?
It's applicable to something like A that
is a voice model. It's applicable to
coding agents, to Ops Run Books.
Um it's applicable to onboarding flows,
right? The same rule applies, right? We
want to find a way to not let the model
think, but building abstractions around
it. So, a good way to to remember on
whether you should use this abstraction
is essentially to think about the
reliability of your agent, right? If
it's somewhat of a coin flip, then you
want to take the control flow out of the
model. You want the model to not make as
many decisions as it should and instead
build those decisions around the model
and simply feed an easy input so that
the model can easily produce an output,
right? So, don't let the model talk,
right? Or actually let it talk, but
don't let it drive.
So, we're Joel and Ornella. This is Ace,
and if you have any questions, please
let us know. Thank you.
>> Thank you.